[موسيقى]
حلا شيحه يعني حره في حوار خل الحجاب او
مش خل الحجاب هي حره وانعم وكل واحد حر في
شخصيته حر بطريقه تفكيره وحر في تصرفاته
وهو ينعم بس اهم حاجه ما ياذيش المجتمع
بتصرفه لان هي شخصيه تؤثر على المجتمع
كتير قوي والله انا شافها الحاجات دي حاجه
حريه شخصيه بس هي كفنانه فطبعا ممثله
عظيمه وكبيره بس هي قالت الحجاب ولبس
الحجاب دي تبقى حريه شخصيه للبني ادم
[موسيقى]
هيعوضها للتمثيل العادي حريتها لكن ان هي
تخلع للحجاب بعدها ترجع للتمثيل فانا مش
مع الحاجه دي لانه هي بتعتبر ممثله وقدوه
للبنات كتير فانه هي ترجع للتمثيل كانت
ممكن ترجع بحجابها عادي والله انا شايفه
انه حلا شيحه وغيرها كتير ان ده قرار
يخصها هي سواء هي حابه تلبس الحجاب او
تقلعه ودي علاقتها بربنا مفيش حد من حقه
ان هو يتدخل